Primero la guerra en Ucrania y luego el ataqué de
Hamás han copado toda la actualidad informativa.
Sin embargo, estas no son las únicas
“zonas calientes” que podemos encontrar.
Otra región que casi nunca nos da respiro es
el Cáucaso. Aquí en VisualPolitik ya os hemos
hablado un montón de veces de esta pequeña y
conflictiva región: las guerras de Chechenia
y el régimen de Kadyrov, la invasión rusa a
Georgia en 2008 o el nuevo papel energético
de Azerbaiyán, vital para la Unión Europea.
En esta ocasión, sin embargo, nos vamos a
ocupar del posible fin del conflicto congelado
más longevo de todo el espacio post-soviético:
Hablamos, por supuesto, del
conflicto de Nagorno-Karabaj.
Y es que, seguro, seguro que todos
recordáis que hace no mucho tiempo
pudimos ver noticias como esta:
N1 (Azerbaiyán lanzó un ataque
contra grupos separatistas en Nagorno-Karabaj,
la zona en disputa con Armenia. InfoBae)
Efectivamente, queridos amigos de,
después de más de 30 años, parece que este amargo
conflicto llega de una vez por todas a su fin.
Nagorno-Karabaj, que, si recordáis bien, es
esta pequeña región montañosa situada entre
Armenia y Azerbaiyán y que está poblada
principalmente por armenios étnicos,
ha sido tomada por las tropas de Azerbaiyán.
Y, vale, puede que muchos os estéis preguntando,
pero, ¿esto qué me importa a mí?
Pues, ¿y si os dijera que la toma
del Karabaj por Azerbaiyán supone una gran
victoria para Turquía? ¿Y si os dijera que
también es una derrota para Rusia? Es más, ¿qué
pensaríais si os dijera que esto puede desembocar
en un grave conflicto entre Israel e Irán?
Queridos amigos, por mucho que el territorio sea
pequeño, la realidad es que por esta región pasan
infinidad de intereses internacionales, y los
recientes acontecimientos pueden suponer un serio
quebradero de cabeza en la agenda internacional.
Pero, exactamente, ¿qué intereses están en juego
en el Cáucaso sur? ¿Cómo ha llegado Azerbaiyán a
hacerse finalmente con Nagorno-Karabaj?
¿Será este el fin definitivo del largo
conflicto entre Armenia y Azerbaiyán?
Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas,
pero antes empecemos la historia por el principio.
T1 (UN CONFLICTO CASI ETERNO)
Nagorno-Karabaj es uno de esos territorios
históricos que ha pasado por diferentes manos
a lo largo de la historia: el Imperio
Mongol, el Imperio Otomano, el Persa…
Sin embargo, en ninguno de estos
momentos encontramos el origen de
este conflicto. Para hacerlo tenemos que
irnos al comienzo de la Unión Soviética.
(Con la llegada del régimen soviético,
Nagorno-Karabaj, que había declarado su
propia independencia en 1918 y se había negado
a formar parte de la república transcaucásica
de Azerbaiyán creada en 1917, pasó a formar
parte de la República Socialista Soviética de
Azerbaiyán en 1936 como una región autónoma.
Desde entonces, la disputa entre armenios y
azeríes entró en un impasse auspiciado
por la vigilancia central del Kremlin.
No obstante, ante la inminente caída
de la Unión Soviética, en 1988,
los habitantes de Nagorno-Karabaj, mayormente
de etnia armenia, votaron en un referéndum para
anexionarse a la República Socialista Soviética
de Armenia. Azerbaiyán rechazó este movimiento y
mando sus tropas al territorio: había comenzado la
primera guerra del Karabaj, que acabaría en 1994,
tras la mediación rusa. Se saldó con cerca de
30.000 vidas, cientos de miles de desplazados
y el control de Nagorno-Karabaj y de otras 7
provincias colindantes por parte de Armenia.)
Desde aquel momento, Nagorno-Karabaj
pasó a ser una de las regiones más
tensas y conflictivas del mundo. Sí, es cierto,
Armenia había conseguido que Nagorno-Karabaj no
fuera controlada por Azerbaiyán, pero el
régimen azerí no se iba a dar por vencido.
Amigos, aunque ambos países pusieron en marcha
diferentes procesos de negociación para intentar
dar con una solución al conflicto, la realidad
es que, por motivos históricos, ninguna de las
dos partes estuvo dispuesta a dar su brazo a
torcer. Al final, acabó pasando lo que todo
el mundo sabía qué pasaría: una nueva guerra.
En 2016, ambos países probaron de nuevo sus
fuerzas con unos intensos enfrentamientos
que duraron 4 días. No obstante, no fue
hasta 2020 cuando volvió a estallar
la guerra, la guerra de verdad.
El 27 de septiembre, Azerbaiyán comenzó a
bombardear Nagorno-Karabaj. Dio comienzo
así la segunda guerra del Karabaj, que duraría 44
días y que acabaría con la vida de 4.000 soldados
tanto armenios como azeríes, y provocaría más
de 100.000 armenios del Karabaj desplazados.
Esta guerra terminó con un nuevo
acuerdo impulsado, otra vez, por Rusia.
Sin embargo, en septiembre de 2023 volvimos a
ver el rotundo fracaso de los acuerdos de alto
el fuego entre estos dos países. Azerbaiyán
rompió la baraja y se hizo con el control.
Pero, ¿por qué falló esta vez el acuerdo?
¿Había realmente una verdadera voluntad
de paz entre las partes? ¿Qué consecuencias
puede tener esta acción? Pues bien, veámoslo.
T2 (EL VICTORIOSO AZERBAIYÁN)
Armenia y Azerbaiyán son como
dos hermanos que no se dan tregua cuando ambos
quieren lo mismo, en este caso Nagorno-Karabaj.
A lo largo de los años han tenido numerosos
altos el fuego, que al final siempre se han
acabado rompiendo en mayor o menor medida. Por
eso, la gran mayoría de analistas acertaron
al prever que el alto al fuego alcanzado en
2020 también acabaría rompiéndose. Y es que,
mis queridos amigos de VisualPolitik, el acuerdo
tuvo serios problemas desde el principio.
(Ya desde el momento de las negociaciones, tanto
Armenia como Azerbaiyán señalaron importantes
incongruencias en el texto del acuerdo. Por
ejemplo, mientras un artículo permitía a ambos
países mantener los territorios conseguidos
en el conflicto hasta el momento de la firma
del acuerdo, otro indicaba la obligación
de la retirada de las tropas armenias.
No obstante, hubo otros problemas en cuanto a la
aplicación del propio acuerdo. Armenia se negó a
la creación del corredor de zangezur en el sur del
país. Además, ambos países se negaron a devolver a
todos los desplazados del conflicto a sus hogares
de manera segura, aun con el apoyo de ACNUR. Y,
es más, Rusia, que era la encargada de supervisar
la paz entre ambos países no logró separar,
de manera eficaz, a las tropas de estos.)
Tanto Armenia como Azerbaiyán eran conscientes
del desastre que supuso el acuerdo,
y por eso previeron la posibilidad de
un nuevo conflicto en el futuro.
De hecho, lejos de traer la paz,
¿sabéis que logró el acuerdo del alto al fuego
del 2020? Que ambos países se armaran aún más.
De hecho, para que os hagáis una idea, en
2020, ambos invirtieron en torno al 5% de
sus PIB en gasto militar. Por comparar, en
aquel mismo año la media global fue del 2.4%.
(En 2021, el 60% de todas las exportaciones
de Azerbaiyán fueron de petróleo crudo,
seguidas de las de gas de petróleo con un
25%; Azerbaiyán también exportó el 1.42% de
todo el petróleo crudo mundial.)
Sin embargo, como podéis ver,
la inversión en términos absolutos fue mucho
mayor por parte de Azerbaiyán, al fin y al cabo,
este país cuenta con un PIB que, en 2020,
era más de 3 veces superior al de Armenia,
todo gracias a su importante sector petrolífero.
Es más, entre 2011 y 2020, el volumen de
importaciones de armas de Azerbaiyán fue 8
veces mayor que el de Armenia. Una locura.
Y, como seguro que ya os estaréis
imaginando, entre el fatídico acuerdo
de 2020 y el fuerte rearme por parte de ambos
países, las tensiones solo fueron en aumento.
Por ejemplo, a mitad de septiembre de 2022,
Azerbaiyán atacó regiones del sur de Armenia.
De hecho, aquel mes de septiembre se
convirtió en el mes más hostil desde
la guerra de 2020, con casi 300 muertos y
7.600 armenios desplazados. Y, no solo eso,
en diciembre de 2022, las autoridades azeríes
decidieron bloquear el corredor humanitario
de Lachín que conectaba Nagorno-Karabaj con
Armenia, lo que ha tenido serias repercusiones
para la población del Karabaj.
N2 ("Nos morimos de hambre":
Los habitantes de Nagorno-Karabaj temen
por su futuro bajo el bloqueo. CNN)
(“La gente se desmaya esperando por conseguir
pan”: el bloqueo que tiene a 120.000 personas
aisladas por el conflicto de Nagorno-Karabaj. BBC)
Las agresiones de Azerbaiyán, confirmaron una
sensación casi absoluta de impunidad. Azerbaiyán
no sufrió prácticamente ninguna repercusión por
sus agresiones y, probablemente por eso, el
19 de septiembre de este año 2023, las tropas
azeríes entraron en masa a Nagorno-Karabaj.
24 horas fueron las que necesitó Azerbaiyán
para tomar todo el control del territorio.
Y 24 horas pasaron hasta que se extendió el
temor de una posible limpieza étnica contra los
armenios del Karabaj. Algo que, por supuesto,
tuvo consecuencias inmediatas:
N4 (Más de 100.000 personas
han abandonado Nagorno Karabaj
Unos 120.000 armenios vivían en la
región antes de que Azerbaiyán la recuperara
con operación relámpago, que obligó a la
disolución de la república separatista. DW)
Azerbaiyán ha insistido en que la decisión
de los armenios étnicos del Karabaj de abandonar
el territorio ha sido totalmente voluntaria. Sin
embargo, si echamos un vistazo al historial
del régimen azerí, la realidad es que estas
personas seguramente no tenían otra alternativa.
Tened en cuenta que Azerbaiyán está dominada
por un régimen autoritario donde los derechos
humanos y las libertades individuales brillan
por su ausencia. Un régimen que ha estado
alimentado el odio hacia los armenios durante
décadas y que no ha dudado en dejarlos morir
de hambre cuando cerró el corredor de Lachín.
Sea como sea, lo que sí sabemos es que
Azerbaiyán ya controla Nagorno-Karabaj.
Parece que el más longevo de los conflictos
postsoviéticos ha llegado a su fin.
Pero, la pregunta es, ¿cómo afecta esto a
las potencias cercanas al Cáucaso sur? ¿De
verdad las hostilidades han acabado, de una
vez por todas, en esta región? Pues veamos,
si os parece, la letra pequeña.
T3 (¿UNA GUERRA FRÍA CAUCÁSICA?)
Seguramente muchos de vosotros habréis
pensado alguna vez que este conflicto es
más bien intrascendente, algo poco relevante, una
contienda más en otra región perdida del mundo.
Sin embargo, queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
la realidad podíraí ser muy diferente. De hecho,
¿sabíais que el conflicto de Armenia y
Azerbaiyán por Nagorno-Karabaj es un vivo
reflejo de las tensiones entre Rusia y Turquía?
Lo que ha pasado en el Karabaj es el perfecto
reflejo de la decadencia rusa y el auge
turco en la región. ¿Por qué? Pues… Fijaos.
(Rusia ha sido, sin duda alguna, el actor más
activo en el Cáucaso sur desde la caída de la
Unión Soviética. En 1994, de hecho, logró que
Azerbaiyán y Armenia alcanzaran un alto al fuego.
No obstante, Rusia se ha mostrado
como un mayor apoyo para Armenia
que para Azerbaiyán. Por ejemplo, en 1997,
ambos países firmaron una alianza militar,
permitiendo la construcción de bases rusas en
Armenia hasta 2044. Además, Armenia también
forma parte de la Organización del Tratado de
Seguridad Colectiva que Rusia lidera. Sin embargo,
este apoyo ruso ha ido deteriorándose en los
últimos años. En 2020, por ejemplo, Rusia decidió
mantener un papel esencialmente neutral con el
fin de preservar sus propios intereses. Quizás
no debamos olvidar que Rusia es el principal
suministrador de armas de ambos países.)
Esta misma neutralidad es la que también
ha mostrado Rusia frente a los recientes
acontecimientos. Probablemente con la guerra
de Ucrania en marcha tampoco les quedaba otra.
Armenia, consciente de esta situación, ha buscado
acercarse cada vez más a Washington, lo que por
supuesto en Moscú no ha sentado nada bien.
N5 (La traición armenia: cómo el gran aliado
de Rusia acabó acercándose a Estados Unidos
El Gobierno de Armenia ha empezado ejercicios
militares con Estados Unidos en medio de un
aumento de tensiones con Azerbaiyán en la
guerra de Nagorno-Karabaj. El Confidencial)
En otras palabras, que con el alejamiento
de Armenia de Rusia, el papel del Kremlin en
el Cáucaso sur ha ido perdiendo cada vez más
relevancia. Y, ¿sabéis quién ha sabido aprovechar
esta oportunidad? Efectivamente, Turquía.
Turquía ha sido tradicionalmente el mejor aliado
de Azerbaiyán. En 2009, por ejemplo, firmaron un
tratado que les obligaba a protegerse mutuamente
en caso de que cualquiera de los dos fuera atacado
por otro país. Y desde luego, la ayuda turca
ha llegado a Azerbaiyán, sobre todo, en forma
de armas: cazas F-16, vehículos de infantería,
drones Bayraktar… De hecho, los enormes avances
de Azerbaiyán en la guerra de 2020 se dieron
gracias, principalmente, a toda esta ayuda turca.
¿Y a qué se debe la ayuda turca? Pues a Turquía
tiene fuertes intereses en la región, intereses
que se han visto favorecidos por la reciente
victoria de Azerbaiyán en Nagorno-Karabaj.
¿De qué intereses hablamos? Pues fijaos, en
primer lugar, para entender qué busca Turquía
apoyando a Azerbaiyán, tenemos que entender
que el Cáucaso sur es una zona desde el punto
de vista estratégico especialmente importante.
Si os fijáis bien, se encuentra entre el mar
Negro y el mar Caspio, es decir, controla el
flujo de transporte de la región de oriente
a occidente y viceversa; y, además,
también de norte a sur, desde Rusia
hasta otras naciones del océano Índico.
Es justo este lugar crucial donde Turquía
quiere tener un mayor peso que Rusia con
un único fin: conectar con Asia Central.
Turquía quiere conectar con la enorme región
asiática directamente por el mar Caspio para
beneficiarse de las grandes reservas
de gas natural de Turkmenistán y para
impulsar nuevos proyectos de comercio marítimo.
Pero, ¿sabéis qué más le interesa a Turquía en
la región? Pues ni más ni menos que
superar a otra potencia vecina: Irán.
Y os preguntaréis, ¿qué pinta Irán aquí? Pues
veréis, Irán también está intentando fortalecer
su posición en el Cáucaso sur para poder abrir
una nueva ruta comercial que vaya desde el Golfo
Pérsico hasta Georgia, y de Georgia conectar
con Rusia y con Europa atravesando el mar Negro.
Sin embargo, en Teherán existe la preocupación
de que Azerbaiyán pueda intentar aprovechar su
victoria frente a Armenia para expandirse
aún más por la región, llegando incluso
a bloquearles a los iraníes el paso hacia
Armenia si cerrará el corredor de Zanzegur,
lo que desbarataría todos sus planes.
Por eso, Irán se ha posicionado y se
seguirá posicionando a favor de Armenia.
Y claro… La presencia de Irán nunca pasa
desapercibida: ¿Sabéis qué otro país se ha
visto envuelto en todo este lío justo por
el interés de Irán? Exacto, uno de sus
mayores rivales geopolíticos: Israel.
De hecho, Israel fue, en 2020, el segundo
mayor socio comercial de armas de Azerbaiyán,
proporcionándole cerca del 27%
de las armas al país caucásico.
No obstante, hasta ahora el papel de Israel
en la región tampoco ha sido tan determinante
como el de Turquía o el de Rusia. Pero
eso podría estar a punto de cambiar.
Con el repentino aumento de las hostilidades
entre Israel y Palestina, tras el brutal ataque
terrorista de Hamás, el escenario geopolítico
de Oriente Próximo y Medio está a punto de
volver a convertirse en un hervidero.
No debemos olvidar aquí que Irán tiene
fuertes vínculos no solo con el terrorismo de
Hezbolá en el Líbano, sino también con Hamás
en la franja de Gaza. De seguir aumentando
las hostilidades entre Israel y Palestina,
es muy probable que tanto Israel como Irán
intensifiquen su particular Guerra Fría
hasta el punto de afectar también al Cáucaso sur:
Israel apoyando a Azerbaiyán, e Irán a Armenia.
Así que ya lo veis, mis queridos amigos
de VisualPolitik, Azerbaiyán parece haber
acabado de una vez por todas con el conflicto
de Nagorno-Karabaj. Ya se ha hecho con todo
el territorio y Armenia no parece tener
las fuerzas suficientes para revertir la
situación. No obstante, mientras este conflicto
se cierra, Armenia y Azerbaiyán corren el riesgo
de verse atrapados en el juego de grandes
potencias como Rusia, Turquía, Irán o Israel.
Solo el tiempo nos sacará de dudas, pero hasta
entonces la pregunta es para vosotros: ¿creéis
que Armenia intentará tomar Nagorno-Karabaj?
¿Puede Rusia recuperar su influencia en el Cáucaso
sur? ¿Será esta pequeña región utilizada
como escenario de un conflicto indirecto
entre Irán e Israel? Podéis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios. Como siempre,
no olvidéis que aquí en VisualPolitik sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así que suscribíos
a este canal y dadle a la campanita para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE y nos
vemos en el próximo. Un saludo y hasta pronto.